hey guys how's it going good morning
it's good morning for me I just woke up
genna's over there making breakfast I
was reading on Twitter somebody said you
see why don't you make a new updated
what's on my iPhone and I said you know
what that's a great idea walk downstairs
brush my hair
Jenna's making breakfast and here we are
making the video and to one of my sides
here depending upon which place looks
better if I want to cover up Jenna make
breakfast or this side of the kitchen
I'm gonna do it what's on my iPhone and
this is an updated version from when I
first got my phone to what I'm using now
so my first page I've got my calendar
I've got the App Store I've got the
settings the clock Apple Maps
Google Maps notes swarm which if you
guys have ever you swarm it's a check-in
app so you can like check-in to tell
your location of where you are to your
friends and here's my Instagram app so
we have hyperlapse layout boomerang
Instagram vine Twitter tweet BOTS so
basically a Twitter entry but are both
Twitter apps but I use them both for
whatever reason snapchat if you want to
follow me you can follow me I just steam
I've been posting some really great snap
content
haven't I Jenna so let's say something
don't do it what's this there's a new
what what is this oh wow Jen are you
surprised hey Jenna
tell me do you want to put a filter on
daddy are you surprised oh my god it
attached to your eyes where did I leave
off oh and snapchat I've got Facebook
Facebook mentions tumblr Spotify Apple
music so knows Amazon and my phone I got
my steelers app for football and here's
my photography section of my phone I've
got the EOS remote which I use whatever
I'm filming with a DSLR so I need that
to control that camera Kinect is what I
use for connecting my little cameras and
getting images off of them on go camera
plus dip tick which is another app that
allows you to kind of put different
pictures in sort of like a little
collage aviary and this toe vsco I've at
my YouTube section here YouTube studio
which is an app that allows you to sort
of control your channels capture you can
film videos on your phone and post them
to YouTube any YouTube app
cool apple stuff this is all the stuff
that Apple puts on your phone and I
don't want to have to see it so I stick
it in there
a piece with messenger NFL mobile sky
will I did a video on that before it's a
really fun game a drop box Oh Eve that's
my period app Southwest because I fly
Southwest a lot flight view post mates
hello post mates I love you that's how I
feed myself
instacart also how I feed myself
instacart allows you to buy groceries on
your home Prime now it's another Amazon
app that you can get like two hour
delivery of certain items iMovie so I
can edit videos on the go Starbucks app
basically my life
uber if you've never heard of uber you
hit the button and a car comes and picks
you up eat24 I see a trend happening
here a lot of food applications a Tony
Bar is a part of Yelp but they do also
food delivery Shazam so that I can
figure out what fast fat feed is dog I'm
not letting you out because you just go
and eat the lawn and just went to the
bathroom so I know you're off to look
bathroom you liar OpenTable also for
food making restaurant reservations boy
am i seeing a trend dog vacay it's an
app that allows you to fine doggie
babysitters and I've actually never used
it before so I don't even know if it
works Equinox
also does use that that's a jig
membership Yelp also for different
recommendations Amazon video for
watching Amazon video a viewmaster space
I did a video on this before it was if
you master you put your phone inside of
the viewmaster and allows you to sort of
see virtual reality stuff pretty cool
ship is an app where you take a picture
of something and then someone comes to
your house takes it from you and then
ships it for you
bitmoji it's if you guys have it moji is
it's really fun you make your little
avatar and you can send little little
pictures of yourself to your friends as
an emoji oh the apples
or periscope for gypsy Foursquare s
flights
that's what developers use to be able to
send you apps prompt smart does actually
a teleprompter for my iPhone I've used
that a lot of times in shoots when I
have zero memorization so that um
Phillips hue this is a great app because
I can use this too
I think you might as might be able to
see if I have some hooked up over here
so if I click read did you see it oh I
did do you see it do you see it do you
see it it allows you to control light
colors and turn on and off your apps
Bigfoot hunter I did a video on that
before you guys know I'm obsessed with
that game and find a freaking big boat I
haven't caught him yet go 9 d that's
another fun app where you guys can watch
videos and all kinds of fun content and
you just kind of go 90 which is 90
degrees turn your friend like that 20
videos over it's a fun little app that
lets you add text over top of things
Zillow for finding homes and renting
apartments Spiro bb8 that's the app that
lets you control bb-8 you know where he
is he's somewhere Airbnb for renting
apartments and places whenever you
travel you now also use for live
streaming you can follow me digest eeen
oh my god this is a long freakin video
thank you doesn't even yeah remotes is
that so I can use my Apple TV with my
phone reach app that's something that I
use for posting instagrams Google
Hangouts Sephora neato that's what I use
for controlling my vacuum which actually
the vacuum is my parents house so I'm
wondering if I can actually control a
vacuum from my phone do you think I can
okay folks let's see if I can start the
vacuum oh shoot it's not disconnect you
robot too far away uh PayPal eBay bit
strips that's also part of bitmoji photo
candy I don't even know what the heck
that is or why it's on my phone peach
that's a new app from the creators of
vine beat sports that was the video that
I also did about the new Apple TV DJI go
that's what I've used for drones
for another video I'm going to show you
guys soon I did unboxing the DJI Osmo
which is a really cool steady camera
square video that's what I use to make
videos square can you leave it anymore
you don't but sometimes I like to have a
spore video okay um that's it the eggs
are now prepared and ready Thank You
Jonah oh let me know what you guys are
using on your phones and I'll see you in
the next video thanks for the
recommendation on the video I hope you
guys enjoyed it
ah I'm gonna go eat my eggs now happy
plus today Thursday happy Thursday or
whatever date happens to be when you're
watching this piece just tell them bye
bye today we're going to be unboxing and
doing a quick overview of the Power Shot
g5x by canon